so we're told that h of x is equal to
the negative cube root of 3x minus 6
plus 12. and what we want to figure out
is what is the inverse of h so what is
what is h
inverse of x going to be equal to and
like always pause the video and see if
you can figure it out
well in previous videos we we've
emphasized that what an inverse does is
it
well a function will map from a domain
to a range and you could think of the
inverse as mapping back from that point
in the range to where you started from
so one way to think about it is we want
to come up with an expression that
unwinds whatever this does so if we say
that y
if we say that y is equal to h of x well
we could say that y is equal to the
negative of the cube root
of 3 x minus 6 plus 12. this gives us
our y and you can think of y as a member
of the range a member of the range in
terms of what our input is in terms of a
member of the domain but we want to go
the other way around so what we could do
is we could try to solve for x if we
solve for x we're going to have some
expression that's a function of y we're
going to have that being equal to x and
so that would be the inverse mapping
another way you could do that is that
you could just swap x and y and then
solve for y but that's a little bit less
intuitive that this is actually the
inverse so actually let's just solve for
x here
so the first thing that we might want to
do is let's isolate this cube root on
let's say the right hand side so let's
subtract 12 from both sides and we would
get y minus 12 is equal to the cube root
of it's actually the negative cube root
i don't want to lose track of that
negative cube root of 3x
minus 6 and then we subtracted 12 from
both sides so that 12 is now
that 12 is now gone
and now what we could do well we could
multiply both sides by a negative one
that might just get rid of this negative
here so we multiply both sides by a
negative one
negative one and then we multiply this
times a negative one
on the left hand side well that's the
same thing as 12 minus y and on the
right hand side we're going to get the
cube root
of
3x minus 6.
and now and this is going to be a little
bit algebraically hairy we want we want
a cube of both sides so let's do that
so let's cube both sides and actually it
doesn't get that algebraically hairy
because i don't actually have to i don't
have to figure out what this i don't
have to i don't have to expand it i can
just leave it as 12 minus y cubed and so
if we cube both sides on the left hand
side we're just left with 12 minus y
cubed and on the right hand side well
you take the cube of the cube root
you're going to be left with what you
originally had
under the cube root sign i guess you
could say and now we want to solve for x
let's add 6 to both sides
so we're going to get 12 minus y
cubed plus 6 is equal to 3x
now we could divide both sides by 3 and
we're all done
divide both sides by 3 and we get
we get
x
is equal to
12 minus y
to the third power
plus
over
3.
and so this if you have a member of the
right one way to think about if you have
a member of the range y this is going to
map it back to the x that would have
gotten you to that member of the range
so this is the inverse function so we
could write h inverse of y
is equal to
this business 12 minus y
cubed plus six
over
three
and like we've said in previous videos
this choice of just calling y the input
well it could be anything we could call
that star we could say h
inverse of star and we're just naming
our input star is equal to 12 minus star
cubed plus 6
over 3
or if we just want to call the input x
we could just say h inverse of x and
once again this is just this this is
just what we're calling the input is
equal to 12 minus x to the third plus 6.
over 3. might be a little bit confusing
because now in theory x could be
considered a member of the range and
we're mapping back to
a member of the domain but either way we
you know the we can we can call the we
can call the input function to a
function practically anything but there
you have it that is our inverse function
that essentially unwinds what our
original function does